WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Welcome
to the Fireside Chat
for Brillo and Weave.
I hope you've had a great
day seeing all the talks here
at the Ubiquity conference.
As you can see, we've
had a whole bunch
of really cool information
just come out today
about Brillo and Weave and
all the exciting possibilities
that it has.
My name's Wayne
Piekarski, and I'm
a Developer Advocate at Google.
I work with the product teams
to communicate information
to developers and
also feed information
back to the product teams to
help make our products better,
and so forth.
So we all work together,
and we run events like this,
and so we hope you
found it very useful.
What we thought we'd do is have
a session where we can sit down
with some of the important
people on the Brillo and Weave
team-- talk to them
about what makes
them do the things that they do,
and what they find interesting,
and what kind of
ideas that they have.
So today, we have
three speakers.
We've got Ryan Cairns,
we've got Paul Westbrook,
and we've got Guarav Shah.
And what I'll do
is I'll start off
by just asking them to say
a little bit about what
they do at Google and what
their important role is.
RYAN CAIRNS: Sure.
My name's Ryan.
I'm an engineering director.
I run the Brillo
and Weave project.
I started the project
about three years ago.
And I take care of all
the engineering stuff.
PAUL WESTBROOK: My
name is Paul Westbrook.
I'm the engineering
lead of Weave.
We're focusing on the mobile
device side and server
side of Weave.
GUARAV SHAH: Hey, I'm Guarav.
I'm the engineering
lead for Brillo.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Cool.
Thanks.
I was hoping with
the Fireside Chat,
we'd have an actual
fireplace here.
But we don't have that.
They wouldn't let us run a
fireplace screen on this thing.
Anyway, today we had the little
pet feeder during the keynote.
That's something
where I was like,
you know what, I really
want this pet feeder,
because it solves a
problem that I have.
And so I thought it would be
a really cool question to ask.
What magic device
have you always wanted
that, now that we
have Brillo and Weave,
you maybe could build--
or someone else could
build-- and sell it as
a product or whatever?
What's something
that's exciting?
Guarav?
GUARAV SHAH: I guess my dream
project is, all the walls are
screens, and it's easy
for me to project anything
on any of the screens,
or rather, the walls.
So that's what I would like
to be able to prototype.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I guess
some of these little boards
were giving-- they have like,
little HDMI ports on them,
so you could do something
like that pretty easily.
GUARAV SHAH: Absolutely.
And you can also drive LEDs and
LCD screens via the [INAUDIBLE]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Actually, one of
my colleagues had
this cool project
where they were
controlling strips of lights
and they were blinking,
all kinds of things.
And there's all kinds of cool
possibilities of little things
you can do that doesn't
require a massive screen,
but you can use really
cheap little components
to make something interesting.
GUARAV SHAH: Yeah.
Definitely.
You can daisy chain
them, and yeah.
Pretty exciting.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Cool.
What about you, Paul?
PAUL WESTBROOK: One of the
things that I want to build
is something to
control my garage door.
Because oftentimes,
I will-- I'm always
worried about leaving it open.
RYAN CAIRNS: Well, then
you just drive your car
and come back home and check
again, and then drive off.
Right?
PAUL WESTBROOK: Well, that,
but then-- you're wasting gas.
But the other thing is
making sure the lights turn
on and off, especially
to detect presence.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I was thinking
I've always wanted something
where it's like-- what's
the state of all the doors?
Show me every time
they opened, show me
a log or something
interesting like that.
Because the door may have
been opened unexpectedly
or something like that.
Yeah, it's interesting.
What about you?
RYAN CAIRNS: For
me, it was really--
I was working on
Chromebooks at the time,
and we were doing a
bunch of Wi-Fi stuff.
And I really wanted a Wi-Fi
router that was easy to use.
So I'd kick that product off.
And then, beyond products,
one of the reasons
that we did Brillo and Weave
in the first place was we
just saw people wrestling
with the same set of problems
over and over again.
Google was getting
into doing hardware.
Everybody was fighting
to figure out, OK,
what Wi-Fi solution
do I need to use?
What Bluetooth solution
How's auto-update going to work?
What's my security story?
And we already solved
a bunch of that
stuff, so we were looking
at, how do we package that up
for people?
That was really
my goal with this.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Security is an
interesting thing.
Because I always have this
terrifying thought of, well,
if my heater is controlled by
my computer, and someone hacks
into it, they can set my house
on fire or something like that.
So security seems
a really big deal
that you really have
to get this right.
And so, what kind
of things are we
doing to make sure
that security--
because it seems like that's
like the number one priority
for a lot of things nowadays.
So what are we doing to
make it really awesome?
RYAN CAIRNS: There's
a few things.
At a high level, we're working
on some platform security
features in the OS, and
we'll let Guarav talk
about that in a second.
We're enabling software
updates, because we
don't think that you can have a
security solution with devices
being fixed in the field.
You always need to be able
to push new code to them.
And then on the Weave
side, I'll let Paul talk
to what we're doing about
local authentication and things
like that.
GUARAV SHAH: So yeah, I can
speak to the Brillo side.
Interestingly, before I
was working on Brillo,
I was working on
Chromebook security.
And we ended up designing a
very defense in-depth model
for building a
very secure device.
And that's pretty much been
verified time and time again
based on various security
competitions and intrusion
detection-- the
performance of Chromebooks
at these kind of events.
So for Brillo, I think there
are a couple of things that
are in boat on the platform.
So verified boot,
which makes sure
that you're not running
malicious code on your device.
I think that's a core
part of the security,
and we talk about
verified boot starting
from when your device boots
up, so all the code that runs
is verified.
Then the other thing
that you want to enable
is, we want to enable sandboxing
and other mechanisms that
are default on and that
are very easy to use.
So we have kind of build a
lot of the same technologies
that Android already has,
plus some of the things
that we designed
for Chromebooks,
like second BPF and other
sandboxing mechanisms.
These are a core part of Brillo.
The final part that Ryan
alluded to is updates.
We really feel that
updates are really
a core part of building
a secure device,
because anything you build,
any software you write,
it's always going to have bugs.
And being able to update
this device in the field,
and doing so in a way that is
very seamless, non-destructive,
error-free is very important.
And so update is a core part
of Brillo security as well.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I
guess one other thing
is that a lot of OEMs
will make a device,
then they just forget about
it, whereas at least Google
does some of the work of
doing the security patches.
And you can just pull down
updates and build it out
without having to have your
own team maintaining all these.
You don't have to worry
so much about security.
GUARAV SHAH: Yeah.
I think a large part of why
we don't see a lot of updates
happening in the field is that
it's kind of always the device
side, the device software.
But there's also infrastructure
for running updates,
for actually serving the
updates, for managing updates.
And with Brillo, we are
making that something that
is the same infrastructure
that we use in Google,
for Chromebooks
and other devices,
and we are making that
available for developers
to use for their devices.
So I really feel
like that really
makes updates a
no-brainer, if you're
building a connected device
using Brillo and Weave.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: See, I've
got to focus on feeding dogs.
I don't want to worry
about all that stuff.
RYAN CAIRNS: Just to add
to the update story--
one of the big things is
like, when people are shipping
devices that don't
update themselves--
the whole internet is moving
forward all the time, right?
People are building new code.
So those devices are just
going to break over time.
They're going to bit rot.
The user is going to
buy an experience today,
and in a year, that experience
is going to be broken.
And what we really
want to enable
is an always up-to-date,
always working experience,
for devices that get better, as
opposed to degrade over time.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
You want to say something, Paul?
PAUL WESTBROOK: Yes, I was going
to talk about the Weave side.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Sure.
RYAN CAIRNS: So on the Weave
side, one of the benefits of it
is actually dealing
with the Google Clouds.
So the devices
themselves actually
have a secure connection
to the Google Cloud,
so they can ensure
that the commands that
are received by the device
are actually authenticated
to come from Google.
And then also, the other part
is actually the authentication,
or actually, the sharing model.
So the user has ultimate
control over which
user, as well as
which applications,
have access to their device.
And so then they can both
grant access as well as
be able to revoke
it, in case there's
a bad actor or some behavior
that's actually not expected.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Well,
that's the thing.
I mean, there's the
possibility of bad actors
at so many places in the
chain that it's very important
that you secure everything.
You can't just get away with
having some parts secure
and some parts not.
PAUL WESTBROOK: We agree.
And in addition to
the cloud connection,
Weave also has local
authentication.
So when commands--
like for example,
let's say the internet
connection goes down.
So commands that go between
a phone to a device,
we can still ensure
that that communication
is secure as well.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Cool.
So one question I hear
people ask me every so
often is, so we've got Weave.
And then we have Nest,
which have their own IoT
story as well.
So how does the
whole Weave story
fit in with what Nest
is doing right now?
RYAN CAIRNS: They're
different product experiences
for the consumer.
From a technical perspective,
we're very compatible.
In fact, we're trying
to offer Thread in Weave
on top of Brillo,
so that people who
want to build works with
Nest devices with Brillo
are able to do that.
So with Thread, you've
got layer 2, layer 3.
With Weave, you've got
higher-level protocol.
And with our Weave,
really the idea
was to tie in the mobile
experience with the device.
So we wanted to focus
on gateway protocols
instead of focusing on more
edge-oriented protocols,
so that we could leverage
the technologies that
are in the phone-- so
primarily Wi-Fi and Bluetooth.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
OK.
Anything else?
PAUL WESTBROOK: In
addition, as some
of the previous talks mentioned,
about the schemas-- so we've
been actually working with
Nest, too, on the device model
schemas.
So there's a consistent model
for actually representing
devices across both platforms.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK.
Cool.
Another question
people commonly ask me,
which I thought
I'd bring up here
as well as that there's
lots of IoT devices
and microcontrollers and kits
and different ways of building
little apps that flash
lights and things like that.
So how does Brillo
differentiate itself from there?
It seems like the
market is quite
saturated with different
projects and companies.
So what are your guys'
thoughts on that?
RYAN CAIRNS: Yeah,
so the thing that we
found with a lot of
these other platforms
is that they're really
great experiences
for trying something out,
prototyping, having some fun
on a weekend.
But when you go to
commercialize a device
or take it to manufacturing,
there's a lot of challenges.
Right?
Then it's not easy
to do out of the box.
And what we have is a system
that you can take all the way
from the prototyping
stage-- where you've
got a bunch of dev
boards that you can buy,
when you've got new
silica, and it's very easy
to move your project
to a new board
without much code change--
and take that all the way
through the
manufacturing process.
And I think that's a
key differentiator.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So
how does that work?
So the manufacturers have some
ability to customize them, or?
RYAN CAIRNS: No,
it's more about being
able to work with
the silicon vendors
and tap into the
hardware ecosystem
so that you can have
a common bit of code,
and then go to a Qualcomm,
or a Marbel, or Mediatech,
or an Intel, and
get a BSP from them.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So they
provide the support package
for their particular
processes, whatever.
So then you can
make your own board,
and then drop their
processor, and they've
ported the kernel
over, and the drivers,
and all that kind of stuff.
RYAN CAIRNS: Exactly.
So you're not tied
into the platform
that you ended up
prototyping with.
You can go talk to
anybody, whether it's
Imagination or Intel or--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Mhm.
OK, cool.
Right now, I guess everyone got
their little kits to work with.
Some people got DragonBoards,
some people got Edisons.
The cool thing about them
is they're very similar,
the build process is the same.
RYAN CAIRNS: And over time,
as people build these devices,
we anticipate that they're not
actually going to build one.
Right?
You're going to be successful.
You go out this year, you
have different silicon
than you have in the
next spin of the product.
And the code,
maybe, is the same,
and we want to make sure
that your projects can--
you can have the same project
on top of multiple boards
that you've shipped, so
that you don't end up
with a morass of all
this code that you
have to maintain for
basically different spins
of the same project.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
So in the past, when someone
made a router or a light
or something like
that-- so what,
they had teams of people
who had to have kernels,
and what's the difference
from before till now?
Now that we've got Brillo and
Weave, this is the workflow.
How complicated was it before?
Do you want to explain
how much people you needed
to have to build a product?
GUARAV SHAH: I think--
the development model was
very specific to
the board, and it
was pretty much throwaway work.
So let's say that you are
trying to build a router,
and you started on a
particular chipset.
You decided to move to
a different chipset.
It's just going to mean a
completely new code drop,
and you're going to
start from scratch.
You're going to rewrite a large
number of portions of things,
because you don't have
things like a HAL.
So the hardware
is not abstracted.
So you're writing
a better software,
but you're also writing
a better software that
is very much dependent
and makes assumptions
of the architecture
it's running on,
on the specific details
of the hardware.
And I think one of
the things that we're
trying to do with Brillo is
to make that to abstract away
those interfaces, whether it's
things like various hardware
peripheral interfaces,
or it's like, how
do you configure your
[? kung ?] specific features,
or APS for dealing with
sensors, for example.
So we're trying to
abstract away these details
so that when you're
writing your code,
you don't have to
make assumptions
about the various
hardware implementations.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Yeah.
It sounds like a
nightmare where it's
like, a kernel bug comes
out, so they might patch
in a Linux kernel or something.
But then you don't
know it's there,
or you don't know what
version you're on.
You might not follow it.
So if you forget to
pull those patches,
you got all these
vulnerable devices
that people don't know
about, it's just-- yeah.
And if you've got a
billion devices out there,
and you need to keep them up to
date, if you missed this patch,
then it could be catastrophic.
RYAN CAIRNS: Right.
And what we're trying
to do is create
a center of gravity
for all these BSPs
upstream in our repository so
that when these bugs get found
by the vendor or by us, they
could get fixed in one place,
and then everybody can
then pull from them
for their own
individual products.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Cool, cool.
Nice.
OK.
We have the audience here.
We have a microphone floating
around somewhere here,
so if anyone has any questions
you'd like to ask of the team--
do we have a mic somewhere?
RYAN CAIRNS: We've got two
mics in the back on the ends
out there--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
In the corner of the
room, we have a mic there,
and a mic there.
If you had a question, we'll
see what we can answer for you.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
So if I understand
correctly, you
want us to make our
devices available on Weave
or through Weave,
but Google itself
will not make Nest
available through Weave?
Because it's special?
I don't understand this.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: This is more
about the Nest experience.
So what does it mean--
RYAN CAIRNS: Yeah, we're
working with the Nest team
to try to make Nest available
through Weave as well.
The big thing today
is that they're
different because
we're different teams,
and we're trying to
align those things.
Like Paul said, we're
working on shared schemas
so that the developer
experience for a Nest device
shouldn't be different
than developer experience
for the same, like
kind of Weave device.
AUDIENCE: So it will become
available through Weave?
RYAN CAIRNS: We'd like to.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I guess
the thing with Weave
is that right now,
we have specs for it.
There's all these
different device types.
I can't remember off
the top of my head.
Do you remember?
It's like light bulb, and--
PAUL WESTBROOK: I can briefly
talk about the schemas.
So we actually have
some device guides
that actually talk about light
bulbs, and air conditioners,
and a number of other things.
But the one thing about
the schemas is actually,
they're composable.
So we actually take the
individual traits of,
let's say, a light bulb
may be dimmable or not,
or have color or not,
and a hardware maker
should be able to take the
individual components that they
want and actually define
the behavior that actually
corresponds to their device.
So yes, we do have
device guides,
but we also define the schema
as individual traits fit.
RYAN CAIRNS: We're
also trying to work
to align the Nest cloud
and the Google Cloud,
so that developers
can work with both.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
The other cool thing
is that, with these schemas,
if you build a device that
implements the
light bulb schema--
anyone can write an app
that controls light bulbs.
And anyone can write an app
that controls air conditioners.
And the app doesn't have
to be tied to that device.
It's kind of nice.
Because you could have a house
with different light bulbs
from different companies, and
they can all talk together,
which is sort of a new thing
that-- I think someone talked
about it today, earlier, during
one of the talks, which is,
you want to be able to make
these things all work together.
You come home, your
light bulb turns
on, your doorbell is
synced to it, your music
starts playing,
things like that.
So people have the
ability to build
these kind of cool,
combined experiences
that has been very
difficult to do before.
PAUL WESTBROOK:
Personally, I'm very
excited about some
of the opportunities
that app developers have now.
I mean, being able to actually
combine these capabilities
into a single experience.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Do you have any
things that you're
excited about in particular?
Is there a particular kind of
scenario or demo that you want?
Because I'm sure
someone will have
one of these built by the
end of the code lab tomorrow.
PAUL WESTBROOK: OK, so
this is what I want.
For example, I think being
able to unlock a door
and actually have your
lights turn on automatically
for you, or based on the time of
day, have different behaviors.
I think there's a lot of
experiences, especially
across different manufacturers,
to be able to actually
have the consumer not
have to worry about buying
one particular
brand of a product,
and be able to actually have
it work on multiple brands.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
The other thing is,
because this is a ubiquitous
computing conference,
and we're talking about
many different areas--
so beacons could be
combined with this,
like a beacon can
announce presence.
You could have a beacon
on your key chain,
or you could have one in
your car or something.
And then it's possible
for your phone to detect,
OK, I noticed you've just
gotten out of your car,
but now you're
approaching your house.
Or Wayne has come home, or Paul
has come home, or whatever.
And you can detect
different things.
And you have different
theme music on.
So when I walk in, I
can have my theme music.
Actually, I remember I
went to a conference once,
and this guy was talking about
this concept of playing theme
music whenever he came home.
RYAN CAIRNS: What would
your theme music be?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
I-- Wait a minute,
I'm asking the questions here.
What's your theme music?
RYAN CAIRNS: I have
no theme music.
PAUL WESTBROOK:
But I could imagine
using the beacons to actually
detect presence in the room
and actually turn on and off
lights, to actually control
the air conditioner fans.
There's a lot of
opportunity, especially
being able to talk to
devices as well as detect.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: What
I want to do, actually,
is I want to put a beacon
on my dog's collar.
And then, I have a
sensor on my couch
that detects when
they get on the couch.
And then it sets off an
alarm or something like that.
Because I actually have a
legitimate problem with this.
A lot of my ideas that
I build are actually
problems that I'm trying
to solve for myself,
but I turn them
into work problems,
so then I can write blog posts
about it and stuff like that.
But my current challenge is
a couch detector or something
to keep them off.
Because it's
actually really hard.
And I would love to buy
something like this.
And like a trash
can that detects
when it's been popped
open incorrectly
when the dog sticks his head
in there to pull food out,
you know?
All kinds of-- yeah, the
internet of dog products.
It's exciting stuff.
RYAN CAIRNS: I was going
to add, the big thing to me
is that we don't make
end users programmers.
Right?
Like I want to buy
all these products,
I want to bring
them into my house,
I want to do different
things with them,
but I want those experiences
to be suggestive.
I don't want to have
to think about, OK,
how am I going to
combine these things?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
I was thinking a
lot of people don't
know-- they want to
have a good time,
but they don't know how to code.
And you don't want to have a "if
this, then else" type scenario.
And I guess that's where
Nest has been successful--
this thermostat.
And it just does
the right thing.
And you play with
the thermostat,
but it's not a traditional,
set-the-number type thing.
It tries to look
at your patterns.
And I guess now people
have the opportunity
to build exciting
things like this.
But that's the challenge now.
And so we've had a bunch of
talks about machine learning
and TensorFlow and all
these other things today.
I guess the thing with
ubiquitous computing
is we're combining all these
different areas together.
So you've got your
air conditioning,
you've got your car
and your-- but you
can use machine learning
algorithms to study patterns
and try to do the right thing
for the user when they want it.
And we have a question
in the back there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I hear a lot of you talking
about both Brillo and Weave
on setting state, on, "This
will turn a light on."
"I will know when a
light is turned on."
I'll have all of these things.
What I'm not hearing are
the inputs for some of them.
So I'm not hearing,
for example, how
to use Weave to create the light
switch-- just the switch part.
I kind of have an idea on
how Weave would do that
on sending it, but not
how that switch would say,
OK, this person
has now toggled--
this person's now issuing
showing a toggle command.
Or even on the Weave side, how
to read for a toggle command.
So that's what I want to hear
more about at this point.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah,
that's a good question.
Yeah.
PAUL WESTBROOK: Sure.
I can start with the
Weave side of this.
So as part of the
schemas, like for example,
let's take a light
switch, for example.
The schema for a device
actually represents
a couple of different things.
One is the commands
that it can handle,
and the second part
is actually the state
that it's currently in now.
For example, an
application or a service
can actually watch the
state and actually watch
state transitions
and potentially
use that as a trigger
to perform some action.
Whether the action happens
to be another command
or happens to be--
whatever it wants to be.
The other part is
actually the commands.
For example, in order to
issue a command to a device,
there is some schema
and so applications
would have to actually do that.
So in the case that you
gave, like for example,
a light switch,
I would imagine--
this is just off the top
my head-- I would imagine
a light switch would
actually define
a state which is on or off,
maybe its brightness if it's
a fancy light switch.
But it would also
represent a command.
And so I would be able to
issue that command to that
light switch to
actually trigger that.
That command would
actually affect the state.
So then the
application, in addition
to actually controlling
the voltage of whatever
was connected to
that thing, it could
also-- applications could
watch that state change.
AUDIENCE: Well,
but the problem is
that whatever is
connected to that thing
is another, completely
separate Brillo device.
So really, I now have a virtual
switch and a virtual light,
and somewhere I need to make
the connection that says,
when I toggle any of
these three switches
on different sides
of my dining room,
my dining room light
needs to turn on.
And I can see how each
individual part of that works,
but I can't see how
it comes together.
RYAN CAIRNS: So the first
kind that we have is very much
phone-to-device, but
we're also working
on triggers and signals, which
we haven't rolled out yet.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RYAN CAIRNS: And that'll
let you do things like--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
That's the glue.
RYAN CAIRNS: --the
device-to-device stuff,
what you're talking about.
Like I flicked
this device, now I
need to go send a message
to these other things
to go broadcast what changed.
Or somebody might have
to subscribe to something
and say, oh, this state changed.
How do I take action on it?
We're working on
rolling that stuff out.
It'll be a little
bit, but stay tuned.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I
guess the thing, also,
that's important
is that the Weave
API is a very cross-platform.
They work on iOS, Android,
web-- have I missed anything?
Yeah, they work across
most of the major devices.
So it's nice, because
you're not restricted
to just forcing it to work
on a phone or anything.
You could build something that
runs on a server in the cloud
somewhere or whatever.
OK.
While we're talking about light
switches and stuff like that,
what kind of
markets are you guys
excited about for
different-- what
are the big areas you
think are going to be huge?
RYAN CAIRNS: We're doing a lot
of consumer stuff right now.
We're talking a lot
about home automation.
And I think the opportunity here
is a lot bigger than just home
automation, which I think is
a really interesting vertical,
but not the whole pie.
The thing I've been
telling the team
is like, think about how we
put a computer in every device,
and what does that look like?
And I think there's a lot of
scenarios like smart cities,
like parking meters
and things like that.
There's a lot of
industrial use cases.
There's a lot of, potentially,
healthcare use cases--
I don't know if we're going
to get into that or not,
but definitely a
lot of potential
to put computers in things.
And interesting
problems fall out.
And I think we can--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Well, that's the
thing with software--
not everything is
about consumer devices.
There's a lot of companies
that do contracting work, who--
they're asked to
build infrastructure,
to put a smart meter in every
house to measure its power
usage or something.
And those kind of things will
all be useful for that too.
RYAN CAIRNS: One example
would be cars, right?
Everybody thinks about cars
in terms of, oh, you're
going to put a computer in
the car, navigation system,
infotainment, that
sort of stuff.
And that's great.
I think Android Auto
is pretty awesome.
But there's all of these other
subsystems inside of cars,
too, that we don't address.
For instance, in a Tesla, they
have an NVIDIA Tegra processor
just running the
gauge cluster, that's
doing some basic graphics for
things like speedometer and end
user input and things like that.
And there's all sorts
of other subsystems too.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Earlier, we talked
about displays.
So the little Brillo boards that
have an HDMI output-- what kind
of hardware do they have
for graphics rendering?
Do they do open gel, or?
I'm not sure, actually.
GUARAV SHAH: Right
now, graphics support
is-- we can support very
basic, non-x related graphics.
But we're working on it.
But nothing to
announce right now.
RYAN CAIRNS: The goal is to be
headless, for the short term.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Well, that makes it
really low-powered.
Although those boards
are really powerful.
They're almost the same chip
as in a cell phone, basically.
RYAN CAIRNS: Right.
A lot of that
comes from the fact
that we were trying to get
something to market quickly.
And Qualcomm and all
of our other partners
wanted to put out a very
full-featured set of boards
so the developers have
access to everything.
And the goal would be
you start with something
like that, that's geared
towards a cell phone,
and then scale it down.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK, cool.
Any more questions?
One in the back there, yeah.
AUDIENCE: This is going
back a little bit,
back a question or so.
So my use case is,
I just got the word,
I'm heading into Tier 3
from PG&E. My question is,
who's responsible around here?
That's a historical question.
Where does Weave
run when you have
a question about a
number of devices
that are all secondary devices?
They're power users.
And I can get how much
power they're using,
but where do I put it?
Do I have to throw it all
the way back to the cloud,
and does that scale?
Really?
If it's a local resource,
is it a capable device?
A capable thermostat
that it would run on?
Or some kind of
neutral gateway device?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: It sounds
like there's logging in here.
Where would we put that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I do historical log--
I log continuously.
PAUL WESTBROOK:
Just to make sure
I understand the
question correctly--
you would like to create a
device that actually tracks
the power usage at your
house, or you want the power
usage of the Weave devices?
AUDIENCE: Oh, of the
lights and the appliances
within the house, not the--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: He wants
to find the culprit.
RYAN CAIRNS: You're
aggregating everything.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Yeah, and recording
it piecemeal.
PAUL WESTBROOK: Sure.
This is possible
to do with Weave.
One thing that you can
do is actually create
a Weave device that actually
aggregates this and actually
represents this power
state as state changes.
And you could actually
decide-- if you don't associate
that device with the cloud,
then that logging would actually
remain local, and you
can continue that.
Or you could actually associate
that with a Google account,
and then that would actually
then propagate to the cloud.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And this would not be
a smartphone platform.
This would be a
permanently resident device
within the home, perhaps DSL
modem, an augmented gateway
device.
Weave capable.
PAUL WESTBROOK: OK.
So there is a
hardware device that's
in the house that would actually
gather this information?
That should be definitely
doable with Weave, as well as
that could run Brillo, as well.
RYAN CAIRNS: It's in the things
like the data retention policy,
and how much you
upload to the cloud,
and how long you keep things
uploaded to the cloud,
and who's allowed to
see it, and things
like that all come down to
sort of both OEM preference
and probably user preference.
And depending on who
made the metering,
or what the user
wants to pay for,
or what the economics
of the situation are,
the device maker, I think, would
come up with a suitable policy
there.
But we should be able to
have a lot of flexibility
in the platform to be able to
do different things for that.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: The
devices can be shared, too.
Like if you came over to
my house, I could say,
hey, I'll share this
device with you,
so you could feed my dog
or something like that.
So you can give access to
other people for the device--
PAUL WESTBROOK: That's correct.
And even sharing
devices, not even
necessarily for functional,
but for viewing access.
So, for example, in the
case of a power meter.
Let's say, for example, I
want to share this device
with my wife so she can see
how much electricity we're
using at home.
That's also possible as well.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK.
And we have another
question over there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I got
a couple questions.
Just really simple is,
what Android version
is Brillo based on?
And then is there any plans
to bring that modular update
architecture to just
standard Android on phones?
So I don't have to wait like a
year for the Marshmallow update
on my phone?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK.
RYAN CAIRNS: So nothing to
say about updates on Android,
but we can tell
you what version.
GUARAV SHAH: It is based
on the latest AOSP sources.
In fact we do all our
development in open source.
And we do it regularly,
not just code drops.
RYAN CAIRNS: Yeah,
we work in the open.
GUARAV SHAH: In
terms of versioning,
I think one thing
to keep in mind
is that we're not using the
same version or numbering
scheme as--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah, it's
not like KitKat, Marshmallow--
GUARAV SHAH: Yeah.
And that's just because all
our development is in AOSP.
RYAN CAIRNS: Having
said that, we
don't want to
encourage people just
to take random snapshots of
AOSP and push them to users.
We want to have some
well-defined releases,
but we want to do it at a
more granular level than what
Android does today with
the dessert releases.
AUDIENCE: And also
my second question
is, what's in it for
Google, or what's
your monetization strategy?
Is there some kind of
licensing that you're
doing for hardware
manufacturers,
or are the app developers going
to have to pay its licensing
fees, or what's up with that?
RYAN CAIRNS: So we're
not taking a license fee.
When I think about
what's in it for Google,
especially when people
ask me at Google, what's
in it for Google, the
answer is, we have
a lot of Android developers.
And we have a lot of
developers that we
want to make sure
that they can program
against the physical world.
This is one way to do it.
We also have a lot of
services, and our developers
build a lot of
services, and we want
to create a platform where
both our developers and us can
easily distribute our
software on top of.
And I think, by doing
that, that creates
a lot of future monetization
opportunities for both Google
and our developers.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: That's also why
we're running this conference,
I guess, is it's part of
all the different products.
They all sort of fit together.
You've got Brillo and Weave and
beacons and wearables and all
these different
things, and they each
bring a piece of the puzzle
that-- they can't all
solve the puzzle by themselves,
but combined together,
they do very interesting things.
Like you said, there's all
these Android developers.
That gives them new capabilities
and things like that.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Well, thank you for that.
The other guys are doing
pretty much the exact opposite.
So thanks.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Thank you.
Question over there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I had
two different questions.
The first one is,
considering that Weave
is a crucial part of
the infrastructure
in communications, what
is your target SLA for it?
And if there's any sort of
queuing in case of an outage
or any sort of downtimes?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I missed the
last part of the question,
but--
PAUL WESTBROOK: Yeah.
Would you mind
repeating the question?
AUDIENCE: Just, what would be
the SLA of the Weave services
as a whole in the
cloud API side of it?
And is there any sort
of road maps for queuing
or any sort of contingency
plans when there is an outage?
PAUL WESTBROOK: Google services
are-- the Weave service
is running in our backend.
I don't know if we
publicly say SLAs.
RYAN CAIRNS: Yeah.
Being that this
hasn't been fully
released to everybody
yet, I think we're
holding back what our SLAs are.
But--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah, right
now it's a developer product.
So please do not build a
nuclear reactor or anything
important with it.
Because that's not cool.
It is beta software, so
please treat it accordingly.
RYAN CAIRNS: Like
any Google product,
we're all carrying pagers.
And we're all trying
to get latency down.
And we really care that 90th
percentile is really fast
and their uptime is really high.
Unfortunately, I can't quote
you an exact number right now.
AUDIENCE: Fair enough.
Yeah.
The second question is, the
whole movement of Brillo Weave
is about interoperability,
ability to connect everything.
But the realistic
sense is that there
are several other IoT-based
platforms out there.
And for you to expect
a consumer to only use
Brillo or Weave-connected
device is probably unrealistic.
And is there any
thoughts-- and this
is not any plans or anything
like that-- any thoughts
from you guys as far as
any future plans or talks
or discussions with other
major partners or players
out there for interoperability
between platforms?
PAUL WESTBROOK: At least
from the Brillo and Weave
point of view, we're open.
For example, if a OEM wants to
make a Brillo and Weave device,
we're not going to prevent them
from integrating that device
with any other platforms.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Another
question over there.
AUDIENCE: Just curious
for your thoughts.
Let's say that I'm a
device manufacturer,
and I'm deciding what platform
to build my new device off of.
I'm kind of curious what
your thoughts on the story
would be that you would tell.
Why would I choose
to build on Brillo,
say, as to just
putting together a set
of yocto patches or some
other embedded Linux system?
Is it just primarily
the Google services,
the over-the-air updates
metrics, that sort of thing?
Or are there benefits to,
say, using the Android stack,
or other things that
you see bringing
an advantage to a device
manufacturer over something
like that?
RYAN CAIRNS: I
think a few things.
I'll take a couple, and then
maybe Guarav can chime in.
But the one I think of most is
the Android hardware ecosystem.
It's very easy to
go to any silicon
vendor who's supporting
Android and say, give me
a Brillo thing.
And the second one is,
obviously, the services
that you mentioned.
There's a lot of stuff
like updates and analytics
and things like that that
you get from Brillo that you
don't get in other stacks.
Guarav, security?
GUARAV SHAH: Yeah.
I think security
developer experience,
hardware ecosystem-- yeah,
I think that covers it.
I think we're also very proud
of the services with respect
to analytics and updates.
I really think we have the
best of the great there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Over there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm pretty sure this is more
of a manufacturing concern,
but we talked a
lot about security.
How about safety?
Like when you define the schemas
or whatnot, are you concerned?
Like I might turn--
a user or a developer
might turn on the thermostat
to like 160 degrees rapidly,
or even other things like that.
PAUL WESTBROOK:
That's kind of hot.
I think there's a couple things.
One is, we are working with the
OEMs and the hardware makers
to actually define the schemas.
So there's going
to be-- the schemas
also support limits and ranges.
For example, let's say
if all manufacturers
agreed that-- I'm just going
to pick a thermostat-- say,
that 160 degrees is too hot.
There would be some
agreement, working
with all the manufacturers to
actually have some fixed limit.
But ultimately,
the hardware maker
is the one that's
responsible for making sure
that the hardware actually
functions correctly.
I think that whether
it's actually
through Weave or someone
just spinning the dial too
far to the right, the device
itself should behave correctly.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: That's
something else to think about.
Because when I was building the
dog feeder, one of my concerns
actually is that if the
dog feeder fed continuously
that entire tub, it can
actually kill a dog.
I've actually taken
my dog to the ER
twice from eating too much.
They will eat too much.
I couldn't believe it, right?
Cost me $500.
But anyway, the point is
that I was like, well,
if the software fails, or if a
wire shorts out, or something,
you really have to build
multiple layers of protection
into the device.
So maybe with the switch
that runs the paddle feeder,
it should say, well,
if the switch ticks
more than four times in a
second, you should shut down.
And if this happens,
you should shut down.
You could have all these extra
safety features in hardware
as close to the metal
as possible to shut it
down and put it in
a fail-safe mode
so that it fails gracefully,
because putting all
the food out is unacceptable.
It's like an airplane
shutting its engines down
if it doesn't know
what it's doing.
You've got to design the
hardware in a way that really
tries to think about, what's
the worst case scenario,
and what can I do about it?
So like if it had
a 160-degree thing,
you'd have a thermal fuse
that melts at 150 to stop it
from getting to that point.
Have multiple levels
of protection,
and don't just rely on the
software somewhere else.
Because the user, if
they set the dial,
then it would be kind of crazy
to allow them to do that.
RYAN CAIRNS: Yeah.
We certainly can't
design Brillo and Weave
to deal with operator
error or malintent
from the hardware
or things like that.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Well, that's
the thing is that there might
be cases where you want
to set a thermostat to 160
because you're building an
industrial oven or something,
and that's a desirable outcome.
So you've got to make sure
that-- the designer still
has to think about these
things very carefully.
Any more questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was that dog
that overate different
than [INAUDIBLE]?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: A fellow
Googler from the San Francisco
office had that dog.
My dogs are at home,
but different dog.
It's a constant challenge.
And it's a great motivator for
coming up with innovations.
AUDIENCE: Early adapter dog.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
RYAN CAIRNS: I
got to say, I hope
you guys are learning as
much about Brillo and Weave
as I am about Wayne's dogs.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: I gotta write
a book about them one day.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: So I haven't
heard much mention of this,
and I don't know,
it's kind of early,
but I was wondering what the
pricing model for [INAUDIBLE]?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: All right.
Just to repeat the
question-- for anyone
else who has questions, if
you could go to the mics.
But the question was, what's
the pricing model for the cloud
services and things like that?
RYAN CAIRNS: TBD.
Right now, there's no
charge for, I think,
up to 500 developers.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: 500?
RYAN CAIRNS: I think,
for early access.
Don't quote me on that.
It might be 100.
AUDIENCE: So some of the
other cloud services, they
offer assistance [INAUDIBLE]?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Assistance
with programming stuff?
Like what kind of assistance?
RYAN CAIRNS: Like do you
want back-end storage
and things like that?
And how are we going to
price those services?
TBD.
Nothing to talk about today.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Right now it's
just bare bones [INAUDIBLE].
RYAN CAIRNS: Yeah.
Right now, we have
crash reports,
analytics, storage for
updates-- Lawrence,
do you have a number in mind?
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Do you
want to go to the mic?
Are the mics ready?
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So for
things like metrics,
the storage requirements
are so low that it's likely
that they'll remain free.
But for updates, for
now, everything is free.
But once we see what
the adoption is like,
and if people start to store
a lot of different updates
and doing it every day, then
we may have to revisit that.
But for now, it's free.
And TBD what the
pricing model will be.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Actually, I remember when
I saw Lawrence's talk earlier.
It has all these graphs that you
can draw of like temperatures
and things like that.
And I think it's
going to be really
cool, because some
company's going
to make a fleet of devices, and
they're going to be like, wow.
We had a huge failure
rate, and all of them
had a little spike
in temperature one
week before they blew up.
And so a week before,
you hear, oop,
that device is going to fail.
We can send a field
technician out.
And so there might
be a possibility
that you'll just
get a call saying,
hey, your oven's about to fail.
We've already scheduled
someone to come out
between next week and next
Christmas to come out.
And they can fix it up
for you, or whatever.
It will be a way of
preemptively doing maintenance.
Because the worst thing
that can happen is,
it's the middle of Thanksgiving,
and your oven fails.
Whereas I think there's all
kinds of exciting possibilities
to learn about your device
fleet and what's going on.
And it helps you with
maintenance and doing research
into making more
reliable products, and--
RYAN CAIRNS: Yeah.
It helps with things
like phone support, too.
If you could give that data to
your phone techs in the future,
maybe that's a problem
that we can help solve.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Many years
ago, I did tech support in ISP,
and doing that was
the hardest thing when
you didn't have remote access.
You had to coach
them through a phone.
And it was even better
when they couldn't
get the phone to their computer,
and then you had to talk--
RYAN CAIRNS: Well, I mean
not so much remote access.
I mean like if you had people
working the call center,
and you knew that there was a
big failure of all your devices
in the field, you
could tell them
like, hey-- call volumes
are going to go up,
and here's what you
can tell people.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Yeah.
RYAN CAIRNS: Even before
the remote access stuff.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
I think it's going
to add a lot of really cool
possibilities for that.
We just haven't been able
to have that kind of thing.
Like PCs, they can kind
of do remote support,
but every other device is
kind of like, press the button
and bring it in and replace it.
And that's quite expensive.
If devices could self-report,
that would be really cool.
Any more questions?
AUDIENCE: That's actually a
great lead in to my question.
We heard a lot about
rollout support.
What about rollback support?
So if--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: As in
backing a firmware update?
AUDIENCE: As in, if you push
something out to the field,
and you start seeing a
tremendous number of failures
with that, is
there a way to say,
OK, let's easily go back to
the previous version, which
may or may not
still be installed
on the person's device?
Because we heard about
partitioning, also.
Is there a way to say,
look, you know that thing
that we sent you yesterday?
Forget it.
Just forget it.
GUARAV SHAH: We can always--
there's always the option
to push back a previous update.
When the update is pushed ,
your user data is on a different
partition, so that's
not clobbered.
So you can, actually, go
back in the same state you
were before the botched update.
But in general, we have actually
designed the update model
to make it easy to do rollbacks.
AUDIENCE: And is
that a real rollback,
or is that just pushing
out a new version that just
looks like the old version?
GUARAV SHAH: So there are
two kinds of rollbacks.
There is a rollback that
will happen automatically
when the device detects
that the new update is bad.
And that's basically-- it
won't finalize the new update.
And it will keep the
old version around,
and it will roll back to it
when it detects that condition.
And if that, that usually
catches 99.999% of the cases
if done right.
And I think we do
it quite right.
And if that doesn't
work, then there
is always the option to push
the old update payload again,
and use that to bring the device
back to the original state.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK.
Cool.
All right.
Well, I guess we're
almost out of time.
Did you guys have
any final thoughts?
Oh.
You had a question there?
AUDIENCE: It was an
extension of the OTAs.
Is there going to
be a certain time
limit the OTA should complete?
Like it shouldn't
take half an hour
if my door lock can't
open for half an hour.
So is there going to be
like, your update should only
take 30 seconds or?
RYAN CAIRNS: So updates actually
happen in the background.
So the device should still
function while updating.
It's when the device decides
to apply the update which
is the question.
And that policy
would be different
depending on the type
of device that's there.
So the user shouldn't
be hung up waiting
to interact with a device
while it's updating.
That would be a
pretty bad experience.
GUARAV SHAH: Yeah.
And the other technology we
have is we do delta updates.
So the actual size of
the update is very small.
So you're not
downloading-- let's
say your image size is 100 megs.
You're not downloading
100 megs, you're
just downloading
the delta, which
might be something as
small as like 6 megabytes.
So that means that the time
to download and time to apply
is also less.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Just a last question.
The main goal of
Weave [INAUDIBLE]?
RYAN CAIRNS: Yeah.
The question was, is the main
goal of Weave interoperability?
PAUL WESTBROOK: I would
say that's one goal.
The other goal is
actually enabling-- well,
security is always a goal.
But I think it's enabling
application and device
developers.
So I think that with the
Weave APIs in Android and iOS
and web, it's very easy to
write an application that
talked to multiple devices.
RYAN CAIRNS: And one thing
that we haven't mentioned
about Weave is smart setup.
One of the big
challenges that we see
is when users take
these devices home,
the first step is
getting it on your Wi-Fi.
The second step might be
provisioning an account.
And the third step might
be downloading the app.
And with the smart
setup stuff, you
can just go and say OK,
Google, set up my device.
We scan for the
device, you select it.
The app for that
device automatically
downloads in the background,
and it connects to your Wi-Fi
automatically.
So the provisioning of
it is very seamless.
And what we find for legacy
products are things like--
things that were designed to
be used in a dumb way and maybe
a smart way is that--
AUDIENCE: For dumb
TV remote controls.
RYAN CAIRNS: Potentially
still dumb TV
remote controls, as well as
smart TV remote controls,
but yeah.
But the idea is
that you don't have
these misconfigured devices.
There's a lot of people who
sell Wi-Fi enabled devices
where something like
50%, 60% of the users
don't actually connect
them to Wi-Fi ever.
And one of the goals
of Weave is making sure
that the complete experience
is configured out of the box
without much effort.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah.
Nice.
OK, well, we're
kind of out of time.
We got another
session coming up.
At the end of this
session, we have
a bunch of demos happening
during the cocktail hour.
So some Googlers have actually
brought in machines and devices
that they've built to show
off some things that they've
done with Brillo and Weave.
We've got that happening.
We're all going to be
around to ask questions of.
And then tomorrow,
in the code lab room,
which is outside the building
and one building over,
we have computers set up where
you can try out the Brillo
BDK on one of our machines.
You can also show up
with your own laptop.
And we're going to
have office hours,
where various people from
the Brillo and Weave teams--
all kinds of different people,
like engineers, programmers,
managers, things like that--
everyone's going to be there.
And you can ask
questions, show them code,
or we can walk you through the
code labs and things like that.
And if you've had trouble
setting up one of your devices
that you got in
your little toolbox,
we can help out
things like that.
So there's a lot of-- please
take advantage of the fact
that everyone's here
tomorrow, and enjoy that.
So that's the end
of this session.
Thanks very much for
coming by, and we
hope you all had a good time.
Thank you.